I'm a pro okay and part of being a pro
is you got to know what's going on okay
so you know are we going to acknowledge
that we know no we're going to do what
we do I mean it's a funny process
because you know a voce the second
person to walk in the front door was was
Ruth reichel when we put open publicly
you know Frank Bruni came in the second
night we were there you know that's
another family that's happened in New
York is that you know between the
internet and the magazines and
everything and everyone is rushing to
get everyone wants the story first you
know any little crumb of rumor
everyone's rushing to get that story and
you know we watch a it's only like six
months ago that I was like you know what
I think were were pretty good I mean I
felt you know that the food had the food
had its voice was complete and we knew
where we stood as far as the service
were the service expectations and it
wasn't the first 52 days our new york
times of you came out which was the last
review we received I mean we were
getting reviewed by by I've never even
heard of some of these newspapers or
websites or whatever and we were getting
reviewed but the new york times is the
52nd day we were open and that's when we
got our review but were five times I
mean we're five times the restaurant
then we were you know at their review
and that's where we aspired to be five
times the restaurant at home in that and
that changes every service but it's a
little bit challenging because
restaurants evolved so the review
process is an interesting one but we
know yeah you know we know when people
people come in it's it's our job to know
when people come in do we acknowledge it
no you do what you do you do what you do
best and you just be pro you know I gave
a speech to the staff because we had
some people
I had you know a lot of you a lot of
people on staff that were worked with me
before over the years and we had people
that never we're at a restaurant that
got reviewed by the New York Times our
new york magazine and you know it's the
same speech I've always given any kind
of like review processes you just do
what you do and you know we'll take care
of the rest you know make sure the whole
restaurant is having a good time the
worst thing you can do is panic and drop
stuff and you know in and fuss and I
went through a four-star review at
another New York City restaurant once
that has been the whole process but much
talked about all through that particular
ravu review because the reviewer thought
she was not recognized but she was so
recognized it was not even funny and
there's no way that you could have seen
that and not known you were recognized
but it's just all part of the the
culture surrounding the you know
surrounding review and you know
different there's some different
philosophies coming out now about that
is it maybe it's better to be recognized
because you know the restaurant whether
it's some pasta joint that's serving six
dollar bowls of spaghetti or you know a
restaurant is trying to really go for it
can really show their ability the best
they can that's the interesting
philosophy you know as opposed to what
we know who you are but we're not going
to recognize who you are or opposed to
just a random person off the street
because you know the restaurant
community New York is very small and
it's going to be two or three times
before you're identified and that's just
the way it is I mean that's part of
being pro